right and he was re i'm talking about
ridiculous he got like top eight at icfc
and i think it was he got like third or
fourth place or something like that but
that's what the thing is about nina nina
will pop up and literally blow you up
and you'll be like yo i have no idea
about how to deal with this thing you
know
the match-up knowledge will pop you
severely you can't wing it with nina
but yeah okay we've got hot topic gin
ready to go
we got you know uh spring nina over here
that's all right
i can't remember the officers are
important
michael murphy okay
he used to dress like this and i hundred
i've seen the people yeah
i've seen i've seen footage i've seen
footage
there we go getting the first round
pretty solid from uh natural
let's see there's an interesting stage
of shoes or they didn't or it was random
selected but we're gonna see how the
infinite part is gonna play out as well
which is interesting
friendly tree not getting the uh optimal
wall handlers for some of these combos
though
yeah and i think it's really starting to
like catch up with them especially if
natural just uses the forefoot
and
so many times he went for the he went
for the four four three one like start
up again so you can use like one two
three one and if you get the four the
the three to hit you still get the free
juggle with one you can go right into
one two four it's kind of crazy and
natural just taking advantage of it you
see it right there it literally did
exactly what i just said
nice oh wait a minute okay finally he
can start getting his game going because
it looks like a friendly trick just
couldn't engage in his play yet but now
he's getting his first opportunities in
it took him two rounds though which is
kind of tough oh there we go trying to
back out a bit huh
with the delay with the audio delay it's
a bit tragic i'm not gonna lie oh dang
i'm sorry bro
[Laughter]
it's like a second chorus that follows
afterwards you know it's a call and
response oh you've got the gameplay
doing the one and then you're doing it a
bit later and it layers up
that's that's some high tech okay
that's some like baroque stuff that's
pretty cool that's okay ah
it's the tail spit
i really want to do this part but at the
echo
four four oh nice punish it just goes
for the hell sweep this [ __ ]
oh no not enough i would have went for
savage
beyond that point you gotta take care of
yourself okay he gives you five you
gotta do something with it okay
don't ask me for [ __ ] yo don't ask me
for nothing i gave you what you wanted
get the t-shirt you don't want to watch
don't make me tap the shirt
people say tap the snap around be like
yo don't make me tap the shirt
video game players don't ask me for [ __ ]
no i'm just kidding
but no
the nina
the nina uh is a character once again
that i feel like you can really take
advantage of that match of knowledge i
feel like that's one of the characters
in this game all this can't have to all
the characters in the game but even more
so with nina it's easy to fall by the
wayside because you don't know what to
deal with if you have even a little bit
of nina knowledge it goes a long way and
i feel like that's what we saw here like
coming from the gym
yeah as long as you know like the basics
so just
you know keep your ground steady
it's just a matter of maintaining your
game and that's what was an issue like
he was always one step ahead it felt
like the whole time he was just like
always challenging him and not allowing
him to like start the blender just like
okay i'm going to start now not denied
objective objective object violet
systems okay
interesting choice
but nina what would nina okay maybe it's
just a feng shui thing it's like they
dig the vibe
the thing is nina you can do these
combos you get in the wall a lot of the
time there's not too many angles that's
not gonna give you the wall yeah i guess
yeah so i do like the stage
i mean in general i just like the stage
i like the music but if you got decent
walls gary like lars on this stage my
man can get the wall no man
well check this out combo video
oh wow oh daddy quarters
look at this okay here we go alignment
butterflies no just takes the the spike
okay
down back three to get the closer
nice
there it is there you go okay friendly
tree taking some momentum
oh counter head
while standing four back to one
definitely getting the wall uh-uh uh
four four three not going to work on us
using 4-4 against the wall not too sure
about it
4-4-3 tries to use that charge blonde
bomb not gonna work out
staying at four
oh this is this is your early tense oh
that's no good damn
one a piece
yo my man starting off every round with
an electric just to let you know
oh yeah
and that's are you gonna get the wall
yeah that low power is a bit
a little cheeky with the delayed hob
kick
down four one four gets the wall split
and the combo on top of it there we go
goes the slide
gets the wake up low
and jab
we're out
no chill okay match point right now for
natural let's see if he's gonna
eliminate a friendly tree from this top
eight
oh damn
he just doesn't get the follow up gets
the spring kick
out of a lineman glow
okay wait a minute
a friendly tree
goes for a reese oh there's the cross up
and now put yourself against the wall
nice and launching oh drop the combo
four four sweep
there it is okay
this could be the make or break for a
friendly tree
nice a little bit out of space
damn natural becoming a ball of thorns
right now not only giving him any room
to come in goes right underneath that
one
wow
for that big low staggie like a big
wow i thought it would roll out and it
does not
unnatural moving forward with a 2-0
against a friendly tree
this was wild that final round was
something
damn
wow
oh man
oh man i definitely didn't think that
rage art was going to hit on the wall
like that
i definitely yeah yeah
he's going to roll out and he just
didn't wow
well that's gonna do it man
oh man a friendly